dépassement de soi partage et challenge
le rallye naturel aventure et de retour
pour sa troisième édition 100%
électrique et 100% féminin cette course
d'orientation est accessible à toutes et
ne comporte pas de notion de vitesse
c'est une semaine de challenge donc on
va mixer des étapes en voiture
électrique et des étapes en trek c'est
un rallye d'orientation au cœur de
paysages magnifiques donc chaque
équipage par avec un capital de points
et elles doivent conserver le maximum de
points en fin de journée pour remporter
son étape et il y a un classement donc
journalier et un classement final on a
lancé un projet qui voulait être le plus
neutre possible pour notre environnement
dire qu'avec une voiture électrique on
est capable de rouler loin et longtemps
100% féminin parce que on est capable en
tant que femme de savoir s'orienter de
piloter une voiture électrique une
semaine de déconnexion totale pour ces
femmes qui vont traverser des routes
pittoresques à la recherche de beaux
paysages tous les jours elle se retrouve
sur le bivouac coupé du monde
puisqu'elles ont pas de téléphone
portable donc ni le boulot ni la famille
ni les enfants enfin voilà elles sont
vraiment entre elles elles arrivent de
partout l'adrénaline fait que chaque
jour elles avancent malgré le fait qu'on
soit pas dans sa zone de confort on
n'est pas dans un lit dans un vrai lit
etc elle s'entraide entre elles de très
belles amitiés du partage beaucoup alors
que l'édition France 2023 parcourera
toujours les départements de la Savoie
et de la Haute-Savoie les femmes auront
cette année le choix avec une nouvelle
destination pour lancer l'édition
norvégienne la particularité c'est qu'on
a choisi la Norvège parce que c'est le
pays champion du monde de la mobilité
électrique ils sont très avancés en
termes d'environnement d'écologie et
puis c'est des paysages fantastiques au
coeur des fjords donc là elles vont se
régaler pour chacune des deux éditions
les effectifs sont limités à 20 du haut
les inscriptions sont d'ores et déjà
ouvertes pour participer il faut être
une femme évidemment avoir le permis de
conduire depuis deux ans c'est ouvert à
toutes les femmes avec ou sans
expérience on n'a pas besoin d'être une
sportive de haut niveau une fois qu'on a
décidé de participer ce qu'on recommande
ces deux participer à des réunions
d'information et ensuite elles vont se
préinscrire ça c'est la première partie
du travail et ensuite il va falloir
aller collecter son budget pour financer
son projet puisque l'objectif c'est de
faire sponsoriser l'ensemble du budget
pour participer à cette aventure et
jusqu'à présent elles ont toutes réussi
l'édition France se déroulera du 4 au 10
juin 2023 et l'édition Norvège du 20 au
26 août 2023 elles seront cette année
encore parrainées par l'humoriste et
acteur Franck Dubosc